right now Will Smith bricks as silence
on the Oscar boycott controversy of
diversity among this year's nominees and
will snub ignited a really heated debate
and when his wife Jada posted a
heartfelt message that she would not
attend this year's Oscars well an
inferno erupted but here's the thing
will had no idea that Jada was the one
striking the match it's a systematic
bias that needs to be addressed across
the industry there's a disharmony that
is brewing in our country and in our
industry that you know I want I want no
part of that will smith was clear he's
not going to the Oscars this year today
he added his voice to a powerful
diversity discussion his wife started on
facebook I'm not be at the Academy
Awards and I won't be watching Jada so
passionate were you aware that she was
going to do that uh no I was uh I was
out of the country at the time and I
came home what happened also today Oscar
winner reese witherspoon called for
change posting quote as an academy
member i would love to see a more
diverse voting membership the Academy
says it's listening and there will be
changes on Tuesday at a regularly
scheduled meeting the Academy's 51
member governing board is expected to
discuss various proposals among them the
membership process and recruitment how
many black films are being produced
every year two-time Oscar nominee Viola
Davis with Michelle last night the
problem is not with the Oscars a problem
is with the Hollywood movie making
system I mean I think we deserve a Best
Picture I got something to say Ice Cube
slammed the Academy after straight out
of Compton snub maybe we should have put
a slavish I think that's wrong Wow just
one random / one random space Academy
members to recognize us
a real black movie I will say it is a
surprise that the movie didn't get
nominated meanwhile Quincy Jones says
he's been asked to present at the Oscars
but says he has one condition that he be
allowed to speak for five minutes on the
lack of diversity